[Music]
hope everything turns out okay
[Music]
we empty out all the money in the cash
register
[Music]
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest
show
on earth
all right
hang on a minute cindy
all right i got an idea for a bid for
colorado springs hold on those cyclists
i'm gonna go back and hit them oh please
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
janice
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
mmm that's delicious and oh i just
realized dave was here last week in this
chair so i didn't fully adjust my
headphones and microphone i have to set
it to human height
hey
i'm kidding i love you
hey dave you've been losing weight
uh don't don't try that now
[Laughter]
seriously though you look like you've
been uh uh a little bit you're doing the
uh the keto jenny craig oh yes yes yeah
i still called 94. jenny as opposed to
the weight watchers what's her name
she's in michigan that lady is she the
lady who created weight watchers she's
super super rich i spent a fourth of
july uh at her house one time did you
really is she bigger now no she's not
bigger oh i'm quite certain she's
anorexic now uh-huh good
florian marks and i'm kidding she's not
in her she's a very very nice lady i'm
sure yeah no she really is wonderful
enough horrible start uh very glad to be
with you
but yes i'm bulimic yes
i'm doing the carpenter diet yeah well
look if it works
i'm doing the watch the drag kids show
diet oh
but i
so
we have a lot to talk about today uh
we're a little late because something
just happened with the uvalde shooting
uh a man came forward and it's a
heartbreaking story but a man with a gun
tried to stop it and the
the police and the feds the marshals
told people to step down so some new
developments uh that really don't make a
lot of sense we'll talk about that we'll
be talking about the child drag show
that's taken place here in texas be
talking about native americans aoc she
claims she's one of them she's not and
also why almost everything you know
about that is wrong and here's the thing
here's kind of the through line is it is
amazing
we'll also be fetching joe biden who
lied like five times this weekend
there's so much to get to no he lied
like five times in the span of
48 hours and it's not even close to
being true there is such a lack of
even the remote
uh
conscientiousness of potentially being
called on your bull crap from the left
they're lying
they know they're lying they know that
we know they're lying and they don't
care anyway and so a question that i
have for you today is does that concern
you
going into the midterms
oh that's the wrong thing you brought up
there
can you can you cancel it there you go
it has to run its course does that
concern you that does concern me going
into midterms a little bit they they
know that we know they're lying and they
don't care anyway yeah
and is it just you know what is
something about stalin something
counting votes i don't know
i forget what are these votes you speak
yeah uh and this is what you meant to
say so if this gets removed here because
we will be addressing the child drag
show
in alice um you can watch us on rumble
every monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern like today it started a little
bit late because of some exclusive info
uh or uh you can watch an additional 45
minutes on uh on mug club yeah which
today we have a wonderful video segment
on mug club that we could never air on
youtube i'm excited from pop's crowder
you saw this clip where you saw a
transgender individual who identifies as
a six-year-old girl riding a motorized
trike
[Music]
it's recorded on a cell phone
it's real it's terrifying
it's the stuff that gives children
nightmares so it's a remake of dumb and
dumber yes
well they're not swallowing june bugs we
have gerald a how are you sir i'm well
how are you i'm okay the air stopped
working at the top part of the house
yesterday so i slept in the basement and
then the air stopped working there as
well ah well my job is complete yes so i
didn't sleep but that worked yeah
dave how are you ahoy i'm good the
quickest wit in the west oh by the way
uh we mentioned that uh early on uh go
to lot of cryotour dot com live with
color.com tour we are going to be uh
june 18th pikes peak center in colorado
springs
this is probably your last chance to get
tickets i think they're about 150 left
so uh if you want to go and purchase
them it's the earlier show we had to add
an additional show
because you folks really like the jokes
you good dave i'm good i can't complain
all right well that's nice you really do
look like you're losing some weight i'm
trying i ate a lot of cake yesterday i
love it why did oh i think i know why oh
no my birthday's coming up yeah so we
had closer to the big four i wished you
a happy birthday on friday and then
realized that i was wrong i know
i think i was like thank you that was my
fault
it's fine i've mentioned it just because
it's 40 and i'm not excited about it
yeah that's okay you mentioned i got
scared i was like oh crap i missed it
and i think dave left town and i'm like
sending out a text like hey guys it's
his birthday that somebody's like hey
it's not until next week i'm like oh see
even in trying to be nice he screws it
up i know but he meant well yeah i'm the
age of what my favorite drink used to be
yes the 40. only it doesn't work every
time no
so uh before
before we move on to uh the drag show
and by the way to people who complain
like warriors and those are stuff going
there is nothing more important to
western civilization than the idea of
mothers fathers husbands and wives in
the nuclear family and if you don't see
how
how dramatically insane it's become that
we are now taking children to
cross-dressing strip shows if you don't
see that as teetering on the edge of
losing civilization then you and i just
disagree
yeah so don't ask me to stop covering
i'm not no i think teetering is a nice
word yes yes if you think it's i think
it's well passed yes uttering yes
uh so before that though something that
actually this country you know one
it's a great i mean i don't wanna say
once was great it's still a great
country yeah and it'll be great again
you know after the midterms and
hopefully 2024. uh but uh june 6 1944
allied forces of course uh stormed the
beaches of normandy and uh that was one
of the most important moments of world
war ii i think we have a clip here
i think that was the canadians that were
walking ashore unmolested no no no that
was juno beach this is far more uh
chaotic
we've all seen saving private ryman ryan
it's not quite this i'm trying to raise
my microphone here while we're doing
this during this very sincere moment
well it's the anniversary of this today
1465 americans were killed and overall
416 000
were killed in world war ii in general
right so that's crazy yeah that's that's
i didn't know it was that high i knew
the number was in the hundreds of
thousands i didn't know it was over four
hundred thousand that were killed and by
the way if any of us could have gone
back to that day can you imagine like
put yourself in saving private ryan
you're standing next to tom hanks and
you're like all right everybody's
nervous they're throwing up and you show
myself i'm like man i really appreciate
what you're fighting for today by the
way
in june of 2022 they're going to be
doing this and you show like the kid
drag queen thing about what don't you
don't just you just said this when we
could go to the clip well then we're on
the wrong side of things they would have
been like turned boat around they're
like oh my gosh well hold on a second i
don't like stop the fight right
look at this one guys
we don't believe in everything but
mostly they were right yeah they've been
like so look okay pearl harbor that
one's on you but uh
there's the bay area over there
this is uh
take that area we were blaming the jews
that was our fault all along i can't
believe that we said it was the jews but
this is actually like really severe like
i made up these things about the jews
you're actually doing this
you're actually having
five-year-olds hand dollar bills into
your panties and your orgasm
release the jews and apologize yes yeah
uh this is too much they make the jews
sign a treaty like okay listen we
release you on the terms that you are
now the uh gestapo for all the drag
events yeah
can you imagine the the earnest parts
where he's like he better invent like a
better light bulb or something like that
he's like he better make sure that
the the trans community can go out and
have kids walk the stage with him you
better do something like hitler's just
like oh what is this decadent lifestyle
i'm going to paint it and everyone's
like that's terrible it's like what is
that post surrealism he's like no this
is real it's happening no it comes it
becomes this look i i dress like this
just in drag well hitler was in part a
response to this kind of culture
developing in germany now let's be clear
of course
no one is defending hitler or saying
that he's terrible the only point is
that he would jump on board with it
because he's an awful he's an awful yeah
being probably the worst in human he
would have been a selfish yes hitler
would have been a self tough clothing
yes
drag dancer with children that's what we
are saying so if anyone here is so
really if anyone here is more like
hitler
most like hitler one could argue it's
these people abusing children
[Applause]
[Music]
now to be clear because right now you
have this petition for discovery against
daniel defense regarding the uvalde
shooting you know the manufacturer of a
gun because they're saying it could have
been advertised to children this was
advertised directly to children yes this
event it says the ultimate family
friendly pride experience
fit for guests of all ages really i
don't know i mean
did can milton bradley argue that they
have a trade mark on that and just sue
them
suitable for all ages it's called drag
the kids to pride yes you would have to
drag them there there's no reason they
would want to go there on their own
drag me to hell you want to go play
catch totally different meaning yes
exactly oh jeez and the cats
no no let's say a word that i can't say
i can't say that and the cats and the
transgenders and the silver spoon
little boy in the bathroom
[Laughter]
sun's not coming home and we both know
why i'm a bad father
because he's no longer a guy
a family-friendly experience yeah one of
the family friendly one of the signs
there red uh it's not gonna lick itself
oh god yeah hopefully take my son to the
balls game yes
yeah someone got the owl from the
tootsie pop to sue them how many looks
gosh
well it's not factually incorrect i get
it but it's also sexual abuse yes of
children here's another one i licked it
so it's mine which by the way is not at
all how property rights work so this is
also something that they don't seem to
comprehend in the transgender community
is that not true i've been going by that
forever
it's how i got my house and my car
licking is nine tenths of possessions
yes exactly i've been known about this
all wrong that's all the pilgrims did
when they landed
mine you don't want this anymore right
yeah so that's how they gave them small
pox
wipes
look i just thought it's how it worked i
mean to kill you guys here it's our
tradition of take the tobacco leaves and
place them in our loin cloth
oh my gosh this is
we have passed this down for generations
this is known as young twerking one show
them your ass yes
motorboat until it's mine yes
but
so this is what they had kids doing they
had them handing
dollar bills to which by the way i mean
i know people said what's wrong with
that well it's generally done at a strip
club which uh if you bring children is
illegal when they are uh
cross-dressing i don't look today's
transgender asked what's wrong with that
yeah exactly that's on them you know
what that you shouldn't have to explain
no i shouldn't have to you know what
you're right we all know what's wrong
with you yeah yeah this is why it's
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ridiculous
and here you even have kids and by the
way this is actually really sad
performing with the drag queens
i mean oh my
if you know and you think you can do it
like we do it i want you to come up here
real quick if you think you can do it if
you think you can walk the runway with
the girl
by the way that kid
[Music]
[Applause]
he clearly happy
clearly uncomfortable being there well i
mean that kid my mother beats me
[Applause]
i'm not saying i'm not saying that
they're preying upon
i'm not saying that they're preying upon
easily impressionable children but that
kid was i mean he looked like look like
bubbles from trailer park boy yeah he's
hunched over
and yeah why why aren't you i thought
i'd be seeing a kitty turned out yeah
you did man had a pee-pee he looked like
sling blade when he was a kid yeah i
know and it's like you know they want to
act like yeah this is this is good this
is healthy let's have these kids
the kid clearly is on this is this is
child abuse this is child abuse from
parents and they are preying on young
impressionable kids okay that want to do
anything possible to make adults like
them and they're telling you this is
telling the kids this is how we approve
you were look kids it's just learned
behavior at that point
right it's it's learned behavior and you
are saying this is how you gain approval
from adults is by going to these places
and making it rain and uh walking down
the catwalk with male female strippers
this is what mommy and daddy want yeah
at what point has the problem swung too
far from look we just want to make sure
we have equal rights in this community
all the way to now where it's like no
you can't say anything about kids
five-year-olds being exposed to this and
not thinking that it's wonderful and
applauding yeah well it's a bar
first of all but also let's say you
argue that they're not all scantily clad
the there's a light on the wall that
says it's not going to lick itself right
it didn't turn off the light right this
is it's not going to lick itself yeah
matter of fact they actually added it
for this event that was a light bright
that was a custom made light bright
light bright time for light bright
remember that commercial yeah only it
sticks
yes good night light bright yes i'll
suck it in the morning yes
it won't do it itself like right
very true he's talking to his uncle yeah
he's wearing a wig good night uh well
save money on teddy ruxpin because they
don't need the animatronic mouth it's
just permanently open
[Music]
good night light bright mr light bright
oh my gosh hopefully none of the kids
could read yeah oh i'm sure they can i'm
willing about a good portion of those
drag strippers couldn't read what parent
does this like what parent in the world
says this is a good idea the parent who
by the way the parents who by the way
got our previous and this is why we ask
that you watch on rumble and uh and on
uh on mug club got our previous video
removed because we insinuated that the
transgender community wasn't was
targeting children remember that episode
was removed you can watch that episode
in the band archive on mug club it was
one of them which was banned
unbelievable they said you can't
insinuate that they're coming for
children you can't insinuate that
remember we had these conversations can
we say can we say it now is it fair game
if we have video evidence of them for
children in a specific instance here can
we say it now uh i don't know a cuck's
husband who throws away a football and a
baseball bat into a trash can with a
little tear in his eye
yeah
that's actually a good point also by the
way i wouldn't take my kids here for the
same reason i wouldn't take them to a
normal strip club what do you mean
heterosexual heteronormative strip club
meaning not weird i wouldn't take them
to a normal strip club because i'm a
decent human being
you don't take kids to a strip club this
is a good point that you made it's a bar
i remember when i was 17 or if i was
doing stan they used to like you have to
wait to do your set you can't yeah you
can't bring kids to a stand-up comedy
club no no and it's not even it's a gay
bar yes it's not a regular bar and i'm
not saying you know the gay bar is the
worst thing in the world but they have
signs that say it won't lick itself well
that's a that is a particular fetish it
is like i don't know a casino yep yeah
yep which by the way we're going to be
talking about native american and
aoc a little later on
well
the aoc casino yeah the eos
we tried to make them but never pays out
jackpots it doesn't no it doesn't
because it's under constant renovation
you just bet with her eyes the security
cameras can never look the same
directions
snake eyes the googly eyed bandit
crap says perhaps it's just all snake
eyes yes i hope i get a two
shoot oh snake eyes
all right by the way speaking of this uh
hit the uh share button if you're on
youtube because the algorithm doesn't
like uh anything that we do right now
and i'm sure everything
is talking about the drag kids show they
want it to be in your
do me a favor and then comment below
search drag kids show in texas and i'm
curious to see what shows up
that'd be interesting yeah i'm curious
to see what shows up
you want to create transphobes
we'll just say the canadians weren't the
ones that were unmolested
right different meaning of the word dude
so here's something else that is
important before we get to the biden uh
fact check here um
there was an uvalde you know how people
always mock the idea of a good guy with
a gun stopping a bad guy with a gun
well the fact is we've talked about this
statistically guns save far more lives
than they take in the united states when
you take into account defensive uses of
firearms it's not even close boom that's
done point is over they lose now
uh we had that with sutherland springs
right stephen wilford was on the show
one of the deadliest shootings in modern
american history was stopped by a guy
with an ar15
could have had that exact same scenario
here
speaking out for the first time
exclusively with nbc news cody briseno
recounts the moment he ran outside the
funeral home he works at and approached
the uvalde gunman all happening seconds
after the shooter crashed his pickup
truck how far were you from him i was
from like maybe
eight ten feet around there
and
as he takes out this rifle he's looking
at me and i tell my my co-worker oh man
he has a gun he has a gun
and as soon as i say that i tell him run
run he has a gun i'm looking back and
this guy's already pointing that
at us
and you just hear pop pop pop papa
briseno says minutes later his wife
arrived bringing him a gun just as
police showed up at the scene he says
they stopped them from going after the
gunman but my intention was to
criminally and i mean
i feel guilty man because i mean i
couldn't stop you
the police
is now helping with the funerals of
several of those killed including emery
joe garcia a relative of his i had to
dig the grave
set up the tent
and then lower her casket
a couple of things here uh we're going
to try and get this man on the show
um
you shouldn't feel guilty those police
should feel guilty and by the way it's
one thing for the police to say don't do
anything if they're handling it they
didn't handle it and this is why the
second amendment is absolute this is why
the second amendment is your god-given
right to self-preservation a police
officer
or really any public employee any member
of our government does not have the
right or authority to tell that man that
he cannot protect his and his own that
wasn't his daughter but a relative of
his he had to he to dig a grave
guess what a police officer does not
have the right to tell you no no no no
you don't have the right to prevent
digging a child's grave a relative of
yours you don't have that right we're
going to stop you right there hey we
don't know if he would have stopped him
would have given at least a fighting
chance the only fighting chance because
the police didn't fight the shooter
it's your god-given right to
self-preservation we don't know what
would have happened but you know what
i want more guys like that and i want
guys like that to to not fear
repercussions from the police or federal
marshals or fbi in a situation like that
we're not talking about people going
around hog wild with firearms we're
talking about where would there ever be
a more appropriate situation than a man
crashing his vehicle aiming a rifle at
you guess what he's now forfeit his
right to live yeah absolutely he's
shooting at you and by the way i want
more wives like that think about the
mindset the mindset is somebody is
shooting at me i'm not running and
hiding i'm running away my wife is
bringing me a gun to handle the problem
right i'm not going to wait on anybody
else i'm not going to wait for this guy
to go kill somebody else that's the kind
of mindset that it takes the the kind
that storms the beach when you have to
to fight evil and then people say it's
friends and hides and people say you're
being foolish when you say it's not a
gun issue it's a character issue yeah
you know what we do have a character
issue we want more guys like that and
wives like his like his hey guess what
guess if they were on the police force
and they had the courage to stand up to
their
their chief their captain
their sergeant whoever was it the chief
the police chief in this case he's been
hiding yeah well and think if he had the
gun at the time yep yeah on and done
done
and that happens
far more often than the mass shootings
you hear about in the news far more
often there are scenarios where that man
has a gun bang problem solved 1.6
million last year
an average of sometimes three million a
year
compared to in the teens of thousands of
firearm homicides the vast majority of
which are gang-related
it's not even close but i want you to
see that individual story
and know
that it could have potentially all been
stopped
and guess who prevented someone from
being a hero
was your government who's there to help
i'm sorry the true heroes
tick tock nurses and uvalde police force
the the true heroes
and by the way this isn't the only story
we're hearing coming out of uvalde they
want it all to be about gun control
because there's a there's a lot that
doesn't add up so angela gomez she was
um
she was the mother if you guys remember
she was handcuffed for trying to enter
the school she alleged that we have this
from daily beast federal marshals
handcuffed her because she was
intervening in an active uh
investigation
she also said that she tried to run to
the school after the police told the
marshals to release her so they were
saying you're not allowed to intervene
she was trying to get to the school they
let her go
she was going to go to the school anyway
and then she said that law enforcement
warned her that she needed to stop now
we don't know if this is true
just to be clear
i tend to believe it just to be cl
so we don't know it's her word against
you know the well-trusted federal
marshals
she said that the camera footage that
seems kind of that seems somewhat
congruent yeah you know it would seem
relevant but i'm just saying i don't
want to i don't want to jump to
conclusions
but based on what we know from this
shooting and the chief and how the
officers acted and how long they waited
and did nothing and how the shooter was
stopped by a lone border patrol agent
who had the balls that the entire police
force did not i tend to believe that
she's not lying
she said that they warned her to stop
telling her story here you go
she's on probation for some charges from
about a decade ago
and that she received a call from
someone in law enforcement telling her
that if she keeps talking to media or if
she you know keeps sharing her story
that she might face some kind of
violation for obstruction of justice so
she was holding back from sharing her
story until now because a judge told her
that she was brave and that uh her her
probation would be short
i i'm a little confused here there's a
couple of points obviously the fact that
marshalls were on the scene yeah early
on when you look at where they would
have been located would have been
significantly
further away than you would anticipate
them being there especially if it's true
from their official twitter account
tweeting the timeline of when they
responded and how quickly they responded
by the way they would have to be driving
well over 100 miles per hour to make
that distance
or you know teleport it who knows the
other thing is they they stopped her
because she was interfering in an active
investigation
that's that's a curious way to phrase
hey there's an active shooter situation
you can't go in because it's dangerous
yeah an active investigation well just
like that man whose wife brought him a
gun i could be we'll take hey hey stop
we're investigating that's my daughter
in there hey hey stop
we're investigating i don't it's weird
choice of words
also what is shen probation for for from
10 years ago being a badass and saving
lives well i'd like to know because
that's an insane amount of uh
that's an insane amount of probation i'd
like to see what it's for yeah
dave's like i've done a lot of bad stuff
and i didn't get no i don't know any i
don't know people with 4g why's that 10
years ago that's a lot and it certainly
doesn't say anything about you know
minorities getting the short end of the
stick no and you know what this is
actually an important point too here
look
people talk about finding common ground
well there's common ground to be found
uh on the police force and certainly on
the militarization of police and
certainly the three-letter bureaus that
exist right oh sorry these are the
institutions that you're supposed to
trust now according to democrats there's
common ground to be found in that i
don't think they're efficient
i don't think the solution is defunding
them we've talked about that however
where are we diverges look look the left
for you to believe the narrative uh as
as to the problems with the police force
today
from the left you have to believe
that they had a secret meeting behind
your back including the black police
officers to go out and simply hunt black
people right that's the black lives
matter no justice no peace even though
you're actually more likely if you're uh
confronted by police to be shot if
you're white and you're far more likely
to be shot as a police officer by a
black uh criminal uh i think it's 16
times more likely than a police officer
is to shoot a black man but they want
you to believe that the problem of the
police is they're all racist all the
only
logical leap that i'm asking you make
to understand the problem with the
police force in uvalde is that human
beings are inherently selfish flawed and
often cowardly
that's it no i don't think they didn't
go in because they i don't think they
told that man to not use his gun because
he was clearly latino
i don't think that's what it is i don't
think that's what it was with a woman i
think it's because they were in over
their head they were cowardly and they
now want to cover their tracks because
no one
likes the feeling of accountability when
you screwed up that's it and what i want
is more accountability from police
officers what i want is better trained
officers the same solution with teachers
you know the kind of teachers who take
their kids to drag drag queen story hour
that's really what i believe the problem
is it's a problem of human nature and so
the role of government is to curtail the
problems of human nature unfortunately
now we have a government that enables it
because it's bloated and it's
bureaucratic and it seems to try and
bring out the worst among us yeah but i
would say even you know to let's take
the police out of what i just heard the
news anchor say
did they say that her probation would be
extended if she didn't stop telling her
story well the judge said she was brave
and that would be her probation would be
short she sure said that's what they
said oh yeah but then they said that the
the marshals were telling her oh that's
what the marshall they were going to
charge her with obstruction of justice
and by the way i think if you're on
probation there are some things you
can't do breaking the laws one of them
hey by the way also yeah but that's
certainly not obstruction of justice
when you're telling what happened right
you're revealing the lies i mean that's
obstruction okay i just want to make
sure i heard that right and i did right
okay so that was the marshalls telling
her that the judge said no right and by
the way obstruction of justice would
also imply that there could even be the
possibility
of justice with all the children dead
when you could have acted and you didn't
no there's no justice so this is one of
those things uh i don't necessarily want
justice i want punishment for the people
who didn't do their job yeah not
punishment for someone who manufactured
a firearm
want punishment for the people who
didn't do their job not punishment for
the mom who tried to do the job of the
people who didn't do their job not
punishment for the mexican man we just
saw who tried to do the job of the
people who were too afraid to do their
job there will never be justice
you don't have a corner left his wife
yeah you don't have a corner on outrage
you just have a corner on aiming your
outrage at the wrong targets
every time
all right
here we go let's move on to this uh
unless there's anything else in i think
that's pretty much all i have to say
about that i do think so we're gonna
have some people like why don't you blue
because there are also pricks in blue
as a general rule i don't think that
police are out to harm minorities i
think there are a lot of police who want
to do their job
but i don't think that we should have
effectively immunity for not doing their
job just like i don't think teachers
should have immunity through the form of
tenure for not doing their job
we only government employees have that
yeah well here's the reason you don't
just say always back the blue it's
because it's the same thing with believe
all women i believe them when they're
telling the truth which is right back
the blue when they're doing their jobs
siri sorry that's it you're right it is
rare that women are telling the truth so
they're
i don't know when that started i'm
speaking my truth i remember the first
time i heard that i went what's that
that's just a lie that you believe yes
that's right yeah
my truth it's my truth
what is your truth i'm hold on let me
adjust my balls a woman i'm a woman hmm
oh well i guess that is your truth right
say no more wink wink nudge nudge what
does that mean i don't believe you well
ma'am you have testicular cancer
oh well that's your truth all right
let's go with that
whatever it is let's just set our
appointment for oh say what's the
mortality rate uh eight months i'll see
you in eight months
uh i won't see
and if you don't take it seriously the
lord will see you in 12. yes
ma'am
it's ma'am so uh speaking of people who
are completely unaccountable this
weekend
uh
so it's friday and we didn't do a show
on friday uh well speaking about the may
jobs report and then we also have a
bogus stat a lot of you have asked me to
rebut the staff from the cdc that the
leading cause of death for children is
firearms no not even close so there's
like five lies that were told in the
span of 48 hours and it's one of those
things where i don't want to spend a lot
of time on it so all references are
available at loudearworthcrowder.com
because they are easily rebutted lies
my main question is where are the fact
checkers
where's snopes where's politifact
where's reuters
so this brings us to this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
here is what the former vice president
i can't believe you said that i can oh i
know i can't believe it but it wasn't
you were being gracious in your wording
i just i read that earlier today and i
was just like wow wow
that's wow that's a man this man knows
the people yes he is a man of the people
really not all there he's like the
political uh the politician equivalent
to bill o'reilly just looking out for
the folks you haven't seen a folk in 44
years bill right you would hate them i'm
gonna go grab my secretary yup in the
privates literally so
uh here let's just give you the full
speech which is like 32 seconds or in 30
something seconds how long has this clip
to a minute it's uh like 15. 15 seconds
15 seconds three lies and we have
another clip so 15 seconds and three
lies but we'll just we'll make sure that
three claims that are so easy to refute
here you go
since it took office families are
carrying less debt nope their average
savings are up a recent survey from the
federal reserve found that more
americans feel financially comfortable
than any time since the survey began in
2013. all right so that
we don't need the clip for this one
because i just saw that one but that was
his claim right the claim right there is
that families are carrying less debt
since biden took office uh here's the
truth
no
[Laughter]
it's the opposite of that
debt is up reference available reference
bill credit.com there was an increase in
total household debt in the first
quarter of 2022 increasing by 266
billion to 15.84 trillion dollars ah so
increasing means up yes
what a wait
wait big words
what happened did you go outside or
talk to friends yeah did you converse
with the folks yeah did you what proof
do you have besides everything
everywhere yeah
what a
what an [ __ ]
do we have the clip of the other claim
we can just replay it okay i mean it's
only 15 seconds here just hit the claim
here real quick we'll hit the claim yep
all right hit the clip so in here he
also claims it's such a short clip so
many lies that the average savings are
up ah
since i took office families are
carrying less debt their average savings
are up
a recent survey from the federal reserve
found that more americans feel
financially comfortable than any time
since the survey began in 2013. the last
one's a bogus survey but savings are up
is his claim savings are up
no
no the truth
savings are down
wow
here's from cnbc not a conservative
source americans now have an average of
9 000
less in savings than they did last year
nine
thousand i don't remember them losing
nine thousand nine thousand well they
didn't put it in red and put the little
minus sign in front of it so i was
confused
or adjusted for inflation
58 000 yes
adjusted for inflation you now are owned
by a pimp yes but at least that 9 000
won't buy you near as much now no no
that's great
so you're not missing out on quite as
much the double negative something i
don't know the point is that's two lies
immediately two lies in one phrase
that's what i said you said 48 hours and
i'm like over the course this is just
one and then there's the other speech
that they give about the cdc thing uh so
technically it's over 22 seconds right
i'll just reiterate the claim we don't
need to show the clip again where he
says the federal reserve survey this is
his claim federal reserve survey more
americans feel financially comfortable
um the truth
no
what does anybody think that's true yeah
this no this comes from ipsos americans
are feeling less financially secure in
the first quarter of 2022 than they did
in the fourth quarter of 2021
so his his server that he tried to use
he was talking about if you look at it
it was pre-pandemic well and i have to
under wait why would you include that
why do you mean comfortable
why would you say financially
comfortable what is that wording that
you've chosen like is that like some
loose term like that there's no real
definition of yeah almost almost as
loose as savings are up yeah exactly i
thought that i see i feel like that
one's kind of airtight like in other
words donald trump would say this is a
[ __ ] country and snow pants on fire
washington supposed to be like four
pinocchio's like what would you call
haiti like let's just be honest about it
but in this case he goes savings are up
no fact check that they're down nine
nine thousand dollars nothing no no just
a lot of applause oh good job remember
in the beginning of 2020 uh when people
would get like a five dollar bill and
tip twenty dollars and twenty cents
right i feel like they may have been
more comfortable then
and then something happened call it a
hunch yeah
so just saying no dave that is the
stocks were up and such that's
well that's anecdotal okay that is
empirical yeah roughly
2013 through 2019
let's just say may have been more
comfortable yeah
it's hard to argue with that logic yeah
because there's logic so here's another
part i went to family video
here's another part this is from uh june
2nd i guess it happened june 2nd um so
that would have been thursday after we'd
done the show he claimed and this is
something a lot of you have requested
by popular request by popular request
because you're going this can't be right
can it
of course it's not right
[Music]
so here hit the claim hit the claim
former vice president joe biden claimed
that firearms are the number one killer
of children in the united states
according to new data just released by
the center for disease control and
prevention
guns are the number one killer of
children wrong in the united states of
america
the number one killer
more than car accidents more than cancer
oh my god he said something wrong and
then he went on to reiterate something
wrong he did number one here's the truth
the leading cause of death among
children
ages 1 to 14 years old which is pretty
generous for the term children is
accidents ah
it's accidents
and there's a little more to this too
where then he tried to they tried to do
these numbers where they separated into
homicide and suicide with firearms and
then they also included people who were
you know uh octogenarians but and that's
i'm being somewhat facilitation this is
a big problem though with ages one and
four-year-olds with suicides with
firearms yes exactly it's really you
come home and that cran suicide notes
written out well also the autoerotic
asphyxiation there's i know it's the
children's drag shows leave no one
untouched i know
so here's the truth in 2019 firearms uh
the deaths by firearms spiked right got
it yeah about 3 300 children and teens
were killed by guns here's the thing 85
of those deaths were among eight that
were among 15 to 19 year olds so he said
that's the number one killer it's not
the number one killer of children and
then when you take the total number 85
of them are legal adults
and i'm exaggerating because some of
them are 15 16 but they can be tried as
adults and certainly 18 or 19 year olds
85 and then you get into the fact that
the vast majority of that is in you know
intercity gang violence yeah so this is
the kind of why don't you trust your
institutions
we just got through the federal marshals
the fbi we just got through the vice
president's office right where they're
talking about the federal reserve
polling
and now right here why don't you trust
the cdc because you can go to the cdc
and look at the numbers and look at how
they tried to do this clever accounting
i don't know who they have aesthetician
or a cpa
just shut up and trust them who's the
number one killer no it's not then he
repeats it number one no even higher
than accidents it's the opposite of that
that's been this week in biden
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
[Laughter]
i just come out and say stuff yes but
here's here's the bad thing they're
going to get challenged the press
secretary is going to get challenged on
this and she's going to continue this
line and all of the media i'm black and
lesbian right the first one of my
questions racist that's that's i guess
all we need to say about that
that is the trump card sorry i said
trump i meant the the highest card okay
fine yes i'm sorry i use the word but
then cnn's going to run
oh my god
i'm gonna come out and say it i don't
care if i get removed from youtube you
absolutely should mistrust all your
institutions yes every single one of
them just to be clear i'd rather you
mistrust all of them then trust even one
of them and as long as they all report
up to what you just saw that guy
don't trust a single one of them well
then he reports to kamala so well
you just missed the days when they just
said you they wouldn't raise your taxes
and they did a little bit yeah exactly
because you know they're going into the
days yeah you're like oh hey hey hey hey
see your picture hey hey you're like
whoopsie you're like
i knew you were gonna do that all right
and now they're just like lies yes
wear a mask lies not those the kids are
all gonna die it's the number one killer
okay i meant uh i meant guns but you
just said that ah it's guns
what
yeah it's more than accidents but i'm
looking at the chair right here it says
accidents no
but this is the chart you made no
i can't ban accidents
what do you want me to do with that they
can't sue accident manufacturers
jeez come on
youtube why did yeah and by the way
here's why you shouldn't trust cnn
because you have a guy right there who's
masturbating below the chiron right now
that's why they still have tubin on for
crying out loud why don't you trust you
know we used to have trust in the
mainstream uh we used to have trust in
our media yeah because walter cronkite
wasn't masturbating that night on the
news yeah the guy on the left is wearing
those glasses for squirt protection
right
imagine like look we used to trust our
we used to trust our media to go back
it's just dan rather rubbing his nipples
we're like oh why did we trust him back
then we should have seen him like a
gallagher show yeah
they're both wearing tarps
only stealthy takes his down like hairy
with the feather glue yeah no i didn't
put it on hi this is bryan stelzer going
raw on cnn
[Laughter]
all right so here's something else too
and i know some of you are going to get
mad and i don't care because you're
going to tell me that you're 1 16 apache
shut up that they're already mad yeah i
don't care
no one is justifying trail of tears
there were obviously there were horrible
acts committed
on all sides but look look look here's
the thing
the the native american
uh trump card is one of those sacred
cows it's one of those third rails that
nobody wants to touch and boy does it
grind my gears this idea that for some
reason land should be given back to some
common ancestral existence where people
were all living in harmony do you know
we had one civil war here in the new
world and it was really bad and bloody
before the new world it was always civil
war between tribes it's not even close
you know who would be worse off if the
land were given back to the natives
which by the way is a misnomer if we
were going to get into that term yeah
would be the native americans
they wouldn't have casinos anymore so
speaking to uh her uh i'd have so much
more money yes
give all the land back but we don't want
the whole country to look like every
episode of cops have ever driven through
tribal land recently does it look like
they're living off like you could you
could just live off the land
what is it what does comanche mean land
of a thousand trailer parks
have you guys driven through is that at
a certain point this is what you've done
with it why would we give it all back to
you also why would we give back any of
it we won i know you don't like it but
that did happen and you tried to win
because you were actually killing their
ancestors and you were raping their
ancestors and you weren't slaving their
ancestors then we came here and uh you
know we've tried to purchase land from
you in some cases like uh manhattan and
the canarsie we have a bill of sale and
then you came back anyway
and so we had to start
fighting you
well if stereotypes are so bad why is
the building shaped like a teepee and
filled with buffalo slot machines
good point we didn't make you build it
we were driving to tulsa i showed up and
it's it's all casinos while we were
driving we remember we saw that poster
of the lady with the she had the she had
the face paint on yeah she had the
headdress the bone arrow and a choctaw
casino t-shirt yes you want to know why
i'm pissed off with it come on because
she was white yeah i found that as well
elizabeth warren i am 1 19
iroquois
but you haven't but you're using your
cell phone it's only the 4g it's lt it's
not true 5g it's all right
it's cricket i i i stopped oppressing my
people i don't know why people say that
that's not special yeah my you know i'm
136 with apache oh so your
great-great-grandpa was a rapist right
oh jeez no that's comanche no no no
that's right it's both
i see your point
oh i i guess oh so i gotta go let me go
speak with our uh let me go speak with
our leader chieftain ebt card hi uh
we all wear jeans
he lives off the land but his name means
one who still wears water wings
jeans with sport coat and headdress yes
[Laughter]
one who shops exclusively at brooks
brothers
so
speaking to her captivated audience on
instagram uh
aoc
shared her feelings about her
reawakening to her native american
roots heritage then proceeds to make a
bunch of claims which are just laughable
i
really really feel you and understand
you on this in fact i feel like one of
the things that first started
awakening and connecting me in a deep
way to my indigenous heritage was
connecting with the lakota zoo
when i was at standing rock surrounded
by
native methyl oh
lakota sioux cherokee all litter coming
together
and i looked around
it really just clicked that this is us
like
and and the grace that they extended to
say no you are relative
was
really formative for me
and while we may not
and come from the same exact lineage
there is a commonality to that ancestry
and it's important for us to recognize
that
we
were raised and we were told growing up
that
we
were extinct
that
guyenas don't exist
and it's really important for puerto
ricans to understand that that narrative
is being challenged right now so there
are a few things and we'll get to that
by the way she's talking about these
people from uh from puerto rico who i
believe traveled from venezuela but by
the way you understand the reason that
you're you were taught that they were
extinct is because of leftist
indoctrination they tried to push this
false narrative of a genocide which
never happened we'll get to that but
first let's get i think she's a dinosaur
by the way she's one of them but she's
extinct i'm confused we don't exist
honey we are extinct but what about us i
that doesn't matter well i wouldn't mind
her being extinct she'd come up as oil
and then it's like you know what's the
perfect self starts off really poorly
surrounded in liquor bottles so she um
let's go to the first claim okay so the
first claim is uh she refers well just
just listen to what she says she refers
them as lakota sue
i
really really feel you and understand
you on this in fact i feel like one of
the things that first started
awakening and connecting me in a deep
way to my indigenous heritage was
connecting with the lakota sioux in
stanford all right truth
everyone go to aoc's twitter i believe
it's at aoc at aoc or at google and let
her know that she needs to apologize
because the term su is considered
derogatory by many of the lakota people
just to be clear so she doesn't even
have the self-awareness to be concerned
about that
oh yeah the [ __ ] the term uh natasu was
originally coined by the french later
adopted by the english as su and it was
actually it originated from the uh
ojibwe word little snakes ah and they
were the enemy of the lakota so it was
used as a derogatory term now i
understand that there are different
situations by the way there are
different languages dialects and we act
as though they're not even remotely
similar so this idea that everyone was
communicating and trading they lived in
peace we'll get to the war in the
slaughter of slavery in a second they
wouldn't have been able to communicate
in many ways and if you even look at the
different sioux tribes they don't even
all agree on what that is and the lakota
often find it offensive so right now in
trying to pander aoc miss crazy eyes
herself cannot even stop herself from
offending a group of people by the way i
don't care that it's offensive just to
be clear well yes but lakota means i
think friendly too right so you're
completely off the board there you're
just like oh okay little snakes little
snakes make sense for her little snakes
is that a new rapper yes yes yes little
snake sex little snakes a little snake
until he grows out of it then he's just
snakes yep snakes snakes i don't know no
snakes
it goes lil yeah then he gets like a
flame okay becomes big snake
and then when he goes to the racial
transition theory becomes a white snake
yep and it gets sued and then that's the
end of little snakes we just gave you
the little snake saga little snakes on a
plane yeah
i'm tired of these
lakota on this
plane
so here's another claim that she makes
that they uh all share a common ancestry
which is hilarious
when i was at standing rock surrounded
by
native people
it really just clicked that this is us
like um and while we may not
and come from the same exact lineage
there is a commonality to that ancestry
and by the way when she says not the
same exact she means at all
so
now if you want to get technical about
it and here's the thing it's just sort
of like where we have the
the left wants to tell you for example
with slavery that well you're not really
teaching american history hold on a
second no no you're all we believe that
you should teach american history you
know as it starts
in america american history they go oh
you should teach about the history of
the slave okay well then hold on a
second now it's a matter of how far back
we go because a slave trade existed
before and it exists now so we say if
you're going to teach kids about slavery
you need to teach them about the west
african slave trade you need to teach
them that over 90 percent of slaves were
sold they were not stolen you need to
teach them where slavery originated you
go now no no well you just then you just
want to cut it off to make it seem like
america is the only place that had
slavery same thing if we're talking
about common ancestry i know what she
means to say she's talking about native
american tribes and uh
i don't i mean she wants you to think
that they're all living they were all
living together in peace i guess is what
she wants you to believe that we all
share some commonality that's not true
now it is true that all human beings if
you again change the degree have a
common ancestry according to scientific
american you reach a date where family
trees share not just one ancestor or
comment but pretty much every ancestor
in common and this is really going to
piss off aoc but beginning in 1492 you
begin to see the european genes flowing
in every direction until estimates are
that there are no people in south
america today who don't have european
ancestry how dare you stephen and uh
then she also tried to claim uh i guess
she tried to draw another connection
didn't it
[Music]
okay did she there's so many it's hard
to keep track of them did she try and
claim that something about african
cultural heritage too i don't even know
what that means but did you we have a
clip yes oh one more thing that's also
super important to note is that our
culture isn't just taino it's also
yoruba
so when
our african ancestors were brought and
enslaved to the island they also brought
yoruba culture
which is why when you look at some of
our most famous songs like aguamile
they talk about
yemaya yamaya oh
just let the world burn yeah
i i quit what's the point
she she's a drawing right like those are
that's anime yeah you would think yeah
they're getting bigger it's like that uh
steve odenkirk uh was the uh the uh
thumb show yeah it's just it's just
she's a little bigger and bigger she's a
little tight that clacky quebecois you
can comment below you know exactly what
i'm talking about
i don't know what she's saying there the
point is she wants to have her cake and
be racist too well she's trying to you
know she's trying to be uh she's trying
to claim all the things and black
there we go what puerto rican and puerto
rico wasn't she mexican before no no no
she was always puerto rican
she might have said she was mexican
because she was so traumatized when she
was uh four miles away from the uh cages
no four miles away from well that oh and
also four miles away from the alleged
bomb that was going the point is she
lies about everything oh she was latinx
right sure which is pretty much a
surefire sign that she's not latin
anything correct yeah
i don't understand that guy who wanted
to stop the uvalde shooter who was told
to stand down by the police with his gun
you think he he would be like hey you
didn't use let you didn't use my
pronouns bro
my good friend justin's puerto rican and
when we were kids i never once thought
he was extinct no
i don't i don't know what i just saw
well you know what words and definitions
change there are people that vote for
this person yes that is the truly scary
part there's people who love her yeah
she's popular yeah
uh i mean that's a relative term but uh
yeah and that very small subset of crazy
in that area of the country here's
something else doing this this kind of
gets us syphilis is popular technically
technically it's a household name it's
si philes
and gonorrhea
in diarrhea yes
right maracas what are you doing i'm
just fendering for votes why are you
talking like that stop just let me have
this syphilis is not hispanic
could be
is it african you're racist you're
racist
i'm doing my best
so where are your eyes going they're
just in a different room right
here's a claim that they she she talks
about standing rock okay and this is
something that uh look we're dealing
with the native american uh sort of
culture here
and she uses the term indigenous which i
believe you're not supposed to use in
that video but i don't know
the point is we learned uh indigenous in
canada and then i came here people told
me it was offensive you're supposed to
say native american they still say
indigenous in australia i don't care i'm
just pointing out the hypocrisy that
they can never live up to their own
rules and it's hysterical so she was
talking about standing rock okay this is
a a when i was growing up remember you
probably learned black hills this is a
big yeah right this is in the dakota
it's acro i think i don't know if black
hills this whole area goes across both
dakotas i'm not entirely sure but black
hills let's just say dakota not the
lakota what she refers to as the sioux
yes um
they were demanding when i was growing
up the black hills be given back right
and she was talking about standing rock
how we were all standing together okay
here's the thing do we have that as we
don't have another clip do we no i think
that was the previous yeah yeah okay so
here's the truth with that when they
talk about handing it back because we
were all standing together
um
let me frame the truth in the form of a
question let's jeopardy this
which tribe
so they want you right now like we're
all holding hands together we're all
we're all unified you were never unified
until the evil white man came you were
all killing each other which tribe
there's so many tribes that have been in
charge of the black hills over the
course of what we have recorded you know
ten thousand years
right yeah the mountain yeah the hidatsa
the the sonish i don't know if i'm
presiding if i'm uh
uh pronouncing this correctly resided
there long before the suit as far as
back as 900 a.d then you had the arikara
they arrived around 1500 a.d
and then there's the the kiowa you had
the cheyenne the crow the pawnee okay
so
here's the thing how far back do we go
here's the thing the lakota
and lakota took the black hills right
took him during that i believe it was
the late 1700s in the early 1800s why uh
well how
they outnumbered the cheyenne yeah so
they took their [ __ ] just to be clear so
you have the key oil and you have the
shine says who do you give it back to
did you give back to the original tribe
or the people who evicted that tribe or
the people we didn't invent evictions we
were just able to sign the notice in a
singular language that's all we didn't
create evictions and at least we give a
warning they just said we have more
people than you therefore leave or get
raped hmm all right i guess we'll leave
good choice
did you give them reservations by the
way did you give them land to go over
and hang out on like we want this land
but we'll give you some other land no
yeah and by the way the lakota beat the
cheyenne at that point do you know how
by outnumbering them i don't it depends
where you go in the estimates back then
it was considered a lot if there were
like 17 000 to 20 000 right there in
that area of the black hills it was
enough for the cheyenne to go oh
[ __ ] so it's just like that just like
that
standing on a hill they don't want to
act like right now like we invented
we invented
war yeah exactly our conquest which
tribe to give it back to right now they
all hold and it's like yes i'm liking
arms well you're the one who raped my
great grandfather oh yeah yeah he took
it how i gave it to him
well you know times have changed not
much not much no we're still i mean once
we get all if we get the land back you
know we're gonna go back to being the
large rape large raping ones yes that
was your nickname wasn't it yeah i
didn't remember i've done a lot of math
standing rock yes named after me yes i
smoke standing rocks i smoke rock
standing
so
let's go harass a kid in a manga hat oh
sounds like a party hey
are you an italian guy paw string is an
indian
so i don't understand how the european
settlers claim to that territory is any
less valid than the native tribes before
them who took it through violence and by
the way we'll get to the point where uh
not all of the land was taken from
the new settlers through violence it was
almost always taken through violence
between tribes not always but they were
incredibly violent towards you you've
heard the term tribal you've heard that
term
there you go so here's another claim
who knows that term here's another claim
that they make that the natives were
jenna it was a genocide they were
genocided right again i told you how
many lakota there were in black hills
back then do you know how many there are
today
registered registered that doesn't
include the fakes who want to tell you
at every dinner party that they're one
portion [ __ ]
uh
000 registered lakota indians in the
united states
they're so we
we genera so here's the truth okay the
truth is we genocided and i know it's
not really a term but that's i'm just
using it yeah we genocide of the native
americans they're more native americans
than ever well then we screwed up that'd
be like after the holocaust there being
60 million more jews than before
we're just they're just bad at their
jobs genocide typically means wiping
people out
there are approximately the numbers and
it's tough to get an official count
i don't know if you know this the
natives all the tribes didn't
necessarily cooperate in a census
try going banging tp to tp taking your
life in your hands
they don't answer and you're like i know
you're in there i can hear you right
you're right you're three feet from me
there's a fire leave it on the teepee
step and get the hell out of here
so there are approximately 200.
literally paper thin
approximately 248 000 native americans
in 1890. today there are 5.2
million native americans and also if you
include alaska natives now i know a
significant portion of that includes
people who are one portion native
american and of course that group does
not include i mean it's almost a wonder
uh elizabeth warren
it's like she couldn't hit the broad
side of a barn with her heritage there's
a good chance that you have some portion
of native american with you the point
here is there was a lot of intermarrying
it wasn't an intentional genocide it
doesn't mean that there weren't war
doesn't mean that weren't worse doesn't
mean that there was an unfair play foul
play on behalf of the new settlers sure
there also
happened to be foul play on behalf of
all the tribes beforehand yeah and they
had a long chance
so when people say give the land back i
mean i you know just
i was just hoping honestly that donald
trump would have just come back at some
point just a mind scream like all right
look we are we're going to give it all
back to
the vikings good luck oh [ __ ]
in this corner
and they're not by the way you're not
even native you're site they're siberian
they're asian siberian when you look at
the people here they crossed over at the
land bridge through this idea that are
they just native because they were here
a certain amount of time ago
my point is no one was really native
here people came here and then they
started fighting each other and then
better people that fighting fought them
and won now
it wasn't only gained through fighting
this is a culture clash that takes place
so here's another truth that may be
uncomfortable for a lot of people as it
relates to the idea of genocide i use
this example quite a bit
you guys have heard of manhattan
small
once or twice yes so manhattan it was
purchased
from the native americans okay a lot of
people don't know this so this is
something that would take it would take
place a lot uh
it was well for 60 guilders
and uh that would include thousands of
beaver pelts that would include uh all
kinds of timber right they bought it for
60 killers there was a bill of sale okay
and we have the reference available at
lightworkcrowd.com we have a previous
show map i don't have all the numbers in
front of me but it was a ton of beaver
pelts timber was purchased the uh i
believe it was the canarsie there was
another tribe and what happened is they
were like well look we don't really have
advanced uh
boats were on this island a lot of them
were living nomadically it was a pain in
the ass and so all of a sudden these
white guys with funny colored beards
showed up and they said hey we'll give
you all of this stuff for it and they
said okay great let's go let's cross
over there where we don't have to take a
boat everywhere we don't have to take
the staten island fair you know
so
they left
then manhattan started being developed
and they came back
well you know we really like what you've
done with the place we were wrong about
this pad imagine if you purchased a
house
right now homeowner and then you came
back to your house
tonight after work and the previous
family that sold it to you
were just living there yeah we like what
you did with our house and you're saying
well but i paid you for the house no no
no no we're like yeah but we like it now
yeah we didn't like it then but we saw
what you did with the plumbing you know
you got rid of the linoleum replaced it
with granite so we would we're going to
live here now and you said you can't do
that only back then there was no police
there was nothing else to do you would
be like now i have to kill all of you
why you wouldn't do that today that no
that kind of stuff happened all the time
back then they didn't certain tribes
didn't have a concept of personal
property so there was a lot of trading
that took place and then there were also
battles that took place
but not nearly as brutal as native
americans were with each other and i
hate even using that term because it's a
bs term that's another claim that they
make the natives are native again no no
no no no the title people where she's
talking about we all share a common
ancestry so she's talking about the kang
oh however she says it i don't know why
i said it with a chinese accent
yeah she did too the point is it's about
as offensive as how she said it yes
they migrated to the do you guys say
caribbean or caribbean caribbean
caribbean okay i guess you could go
either way though i've heard people say
it either way i say caribbean when
referring to the disney ride but why
uh
it sounds better
all right well it follows pirates better
but if you're talking about like if i'm
like somali pirates right
different the last time i went on that
ride i left a grumpy in the boat yes
all over the sheets so she said that the
taino people migrated to uh she said we
all share a common ancestry no the taino
people migrated to the caribbean from
what is present-day venezuela ah okay so
there you go i don't know if
if this is
right you've got north america south
america okay import this is low budget
they came out of michigan they came up
all right venezuela's south
clear enough
now
let's go to all the west but yeah
whereas if you look at the native
americans who would be here in north as
you know them
they came from asia with the majority
coming in one group here you go from the
university college of london reference
available earthquaker.com scientists
have found that native american
populations arose from at least three
migrations with majority descended
entirely from a single group of first
american migrants that crossed over
through beringia beringia burundi i
don't know a land bridge between asia
and america what would probably known be
known as present-day siberia a lot of
people don't think of you know areas of
russia as asia but it actually is as
general patton referred to them the
asiatics so the point is no not the same
at all yeah they came from different
areas and so then it becomes a matter of
who was there first by the way why would
they have left venezuela
that's a question that needs to be asked
i don't have the answer for you right
now because i only have so much time in
the day i'm willing to bet
there were some people who had to leave
venezuela
for the caribbean because there were
people back there in venezuela who said
uh you can be my slave or leave this
place and they said well we're just
gonna we're just gonna leave this place
we'll get in the boat and go out on the
water and thanks know what's gonna
happen yeah
roll the dice see what happens
so this is one of those things it's this
constant it's this constant victim
i mean i don't want to even say victim
complex because that would presume that
there's some sort of value in being a
victim to begin with it's this constant
false perpetuation of victimhood and and
it's not even based in reality you know
i realized that as all oppressed people
the people who left venezuela from their
oppressors and the people who were
killing other people in these tribes
that are completely unrelated that we
all share a common ancestry and that we
need to sign the green new deal more
money please more money please how about
everything you just said is [ __ ] and
we give no land back whatsoever why well
because we want it at this point and
guess what when you guys and when i say
you guys i don't want to speak in broad
strokes because i know there are so many
tribes that exist and i don't want to
disrespect the scalping that you did
amongst each other because you guys were
killing and slaving and raping each
other before we came here and now there
are more native americans or porsche
native americans than ever that's not
genocide that's called winning a war and
then being historically speaking
incredibly gracious about it hey also
send your messages to aoc on twitter
because i gotta tell you she should not
be tarring and feathering the good
lakota people
the good lakota people not like those
cheyenne pricks the good lakota people
with the moniker of little snakes of sue
they don't like that aoc and you know
what that won't happen on my uh on my uh
watch we're gonna go watch a transgender
on a tricycle that my father happened to
record while driving down his uh
oh youtube piss off
so
[Music]